สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูอาร์ตี้
สวัสดีค่ะ
ในช่อง compreter ไทยอีกแล้วกลับมาเจอกัน
อีกแล้วนะครับวันนี้
แล้วเราเจอกันวันอะไรคะครูอาร์ตี้วันนี้
วันอะไรวันนี้
เอาปฏิทินมาก่อน
มาแล้ววันนี้วันอาทิตย์ครับวันอาทิตย์นะ
วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันอาทิตย์ที่
12 ครับวันนี้วันอาทิตย์ที่ 12 เดือน
อะไรคะเดือนนี้เดือนมีนาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ครับ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้ว
กี่โมงครับตอนนี้
7 โมง 25 นาที
วันนี้เราเจอกันเช้าค่ะนักเรียนตอนเช้า
เลยใช่ไหมตื่นมาแล้วก็สอนเลยค่ะ
ตื่นกี่โมง 6 โมงครึ่งอ๋อตื่นตอนตรงนี้
ใช่ไหม
[เพลง]
พยายามคือคือธรรมดา
ไม่ทำนะ
ตอนนี้
ต้องรีบตื่นใช่ไหม
เพราะว่าเรามีสอนใช่ไหมเรามีนัดกันเรามี
นัดกันที่จะมา
สอนด้วย
กันตอน 7 โมง 25 นาทีก็ต้องพยายามตื่นตอน
เช้าแต่ว่าครูเอ๋กำลังคิดจะตื่นตอนเช้า
ทุกวันอ๋อตื่นตอนเช้าดีจะได้ไปเดิน
ครูเอ๋อยากจะเดินเยอะๆนะคะก็เลยจะนอนปกติ
ครูเอ๋นอนตี 2 ครูอาร์ตี้ทำไมครูเอ๋นอน
ดึกจังทำไมนอนดึกเพราะว่าครูเอ๋แต่งงาน
แล้วสามีครูเอ๋นอนตี 3 ครูเอกก็เลยรอ
รอทำไม
ทำไมนอนตี 3 เป็นห่วงเดี๋ยวเขาไม่สบาย
เดี๋ยวเขาหิวน้ำก็เป็นห่วงก็เลยรอแล้วก็
นอนตี 2 เวลานอนตี 2 ครูเอกก็เลยตื่นสาย
ใช่ไหมใช่ครูเอกก็ตื่นประมาณ 7 โมงครึ่ง 8
โมง
ไม่ได้ครูเอกนี่
แต่ตอนนี้กำลังคิดว่าจะนอนเร็วเพราะว่า
สามีบอกว่าไปนอนไปนอน
ถ้านอนเร็วใช่ไหมคะครูเอ๋ก็ตื่นเช้าๆ 6
โมงเช้าคือถ้านอนเร็วขึ้นอาจจะตี 5 แล้ว
ก็ไปเดิน
[เพลง]
ไม่ร้อน
ก็ตื่นไปวิ่งตอนเช้าตี 5
ตีห้าครึ่งครัวตี้ก็ไปวิ่งแล้ว
ครูเอ๋ก็ไปเดินนะคะไม่วิ่ง
พอพูดถึงเดิน
ว่าวันนี้ครูอาร์ตี้
จะมาเล่าให้นักเรียนฟังหรือว่ามาสอนให้
นักเรียนรู้จากเกี่ยวกับพระแต่ว่าก็เป็น
พระที่ไปเดินเหมือนกันไปเดินใช่ไหม
อันนี้เป็นเรียกว่าเป็นกิจกรรมอย่างหนึ่ง
ที่ไปเดินออกออกไปข้างนอกกว่าไปบางทีก็ไป
หลายๆวัน
ไปหลายๆวันไม่ได้ไปวันเดียวไม่ได้ไปวัน
เดียวแล้วก็บางทีก็หลายเดือนใช่ไปหลาย
เดือนด้วยบางทีก็หลายปีไปไกลๆไปเดินไป
ต่างจังหวัดบ้างบางมีพระพระบางรูปเดินไป
ต่างประเทศด้วยประเทศใกล้ๆจริงหรือเปล่า
เราเรียกว่าเป็นการเดินธุดงค์เดินธุดงค์
นะคะวันนี้นักเรียนเพราะว่านักเรียนที่
ที่ฟังเราเกี่ยวกับอะไรนะที่เป็นซีรีย์
เกี่ยวกับพระสงฆ์ก็จะได้ยินเราพูดบ่อยๆ
อ้อพระรูปนี้ท่านไปธุดงค์
ท่านเดินธุดงค์นักเรียนก็
ธุดงค์คืออะไร
ทำอะไรธุดงค์มีอะไร
จะมาเล่าให้ฟังนะวันนี้จะมาเล่าให้ฟัง
เกี่ยวกับการเดินธุดงค์ของพระสงฆ์นะ
[เพลง]
เป็นรูปของพระที่เดินธุดงค์
หรือหลายๆรูปบางครั้งบางครั้งก็จะมีเดิน
ไปพร้อมๆกันหลายรูป 2 รูป 3 รูป 4 รูปได้
แต่อาจจะไปไม่เยอะนะครับ
แล้วก็เวลาเดินธุดงค์ก็จะมีมีอันนี้อะไร
ครับครูเอ๋
บัตรอยู่ในอะไรอ่ะ
จะมีผ้าจะมีผ้าที่ทำเป็นสายสะพายแล้วก็
อยู่ในบาตรอีกทีนึงนะครับบาทอยู่ในอยู่ใน
ผ้าที่เป็นผ้าสะพายอีกทีนึงนะครับ
[เพลง]
ถาดวางบาดใช่ไหมเวลาที่จะบาดวางวางกับ
พื้นเพราะว่าบาทปกติบาทจะเป็นกลมๆใช่ไหม
ใช่ๆ
บาทจะเป็นกลมๆแบบนี้
เวลาว่างกับพื้นมันก็จะเอียงไปเอียงมา
แต่ถ้ามีบางมีฐานมีฐานตรงนี้บาทก็จะไม่
เอียงป่ะก็จะตั้งอยู่ได้
คือจริงๆ
สงสัยจริงๆว่านักเรียนเพราะว่ากำลังสงสัย
F5 แล้วทำไมมีอันนี้แสดงว่าผ้าที่ที่มัน
เหมือนกับกระเป๋าเนอะ
เพื่อให้ให้ถามให้ทานออกมาได้
แล้วเวลาวางก็จะได้วางได้มีที่วางตรงนี้
เป็นที่วางเป็นฐานของบาตร
เวลาที่พระท่านออกธุดงค์ที่มองเห็นตอนนี้
เลยก็คือมีมีบาท
สะพายบ่าได้ไม่ได้กระเป๋าสิเรียกย่ามเนาะ
ที่ทำมาจากผ้านะครับ
เป็นกระเป๋าผ้านั่นแหละ
[เพลง]
แล้วก็
โอเคท่านก็ใส่ชุดพละ
ขาดอะไรไปอย่างนึง
ใช่ไหมกูหมายถึงร่มใช่ไหมครับใช่เขาเรียก
ว่าร่มหรือเรียกว่าอะไรอ่ะ
นะ
ขาดอันนี้อ่ะเดี๋ยวกลัวที่ให้ดูนี่ๆๆๆอัน
นี้ใช่มั้ยครูเอ๋บอกว่าขาดอันนี้
โกรธโกรธใช่ๆ
พูดถูกแล้วครับแต่ลักษณะมันเหมือนร่มนะ
ครับ
เราก็จะเรียกมันว่ากรด
เวลาพระไปบิณฑบาตเอ้ยไม่ใช่ไปเดินธุดงค์
เนี่ยจะ
โกรธโอเคไม่ใช่กรดกรด
ของพระเหมือนร่มเลยใช่
[เพลง]
รองเท้าไหมคะครูอาร์ตี้
ที่ถูกที่ถูกถ้าสำหรับพระที่พระที่
เรียกว่าอะไรเข้มงวดถ้าเข้มงวดมากๆเลย
เคร่งมากๆท่านก็จะไม่ใส่รองเท้า
เพราะว่าคู่เอกนะ
[เพลง]
จะได้รู้สึกตัวว่าอ๋อเดิน
เดินเวลาเหยียบไปที่พื้นเหยียบไปที่อื่น
ท่านก็จะมีความรู้สึกละเอียดไปที่พื้นอาจ
จะมีมีเป็นพื้นดินเป็นต้นไม้เป็นต้นหญ้า
ท่านจะรู้สึกจะได้มีความรู้สึกตัว
เท้าแต่ว่าถนนแบบนี้ร้อนมากนะคะ
ปกติ
ถ้าเป็นสมัยโบราณ
โบราณที่สมัยก่อนนะคะ
สัก 100 ปีที่แล้วเนี่ยถนนเป็นดิน
เป็นถนนดินก็ไม่ร้อนมากใช่แต่ถ้าถนนแบบ
นี้สำหรับขับรถรถวิ่งเนี่ยโอ้โหร้อนมาก
ร้อนใช่ครับ
[เพลง]
ส่วนใหญ่แล้วจะไปธุดงค์ในป่า
ในป่าแล้วก็จะมีช่วงเวลาที่ต้องมา
บิณฑบาตรตอนเช้า
ก็อาจจะต้องเดินลงมาในเมืองพอเข้ามาใน
เมืองก็จะมีบริเวณที่เป็นถนนบ้างนิดหน่อย
ถ้าเป็นถนนก็อาจจะต้องเป็นช่วงเช้าถนนตอน
เช้าเดินมาบิณฑบาตรอะไรอย่างเงี้ยครับก็
ยังไม่ร้อนมาก
ก็คือถ้าพระที่เคร่งมากก็ครับไม่ใส่ใช่
ไม่ใส่รองเท้า
ถ้าเท้าท่านเจ็บค่ะ
หยุดพักก่อนไม่เดินไม่เดินนึกว่ามีมีอะไร
นะมีพลาสเตอร์แล้วใส่รองเท้าได้
ครูเอ๋จะไม่เคยเห็นจะไม่เคยเห็นพระเดิน
แล้วเจ็บขาไม่เคยเพราะว่าถ้าเจ็บขาท่านก็
ไม่เดินท่านก็อยู่ที่เดิม
ครูเอ๋ก็ช่างสงสัยกูเองสงสัยเพราะว่ามี
นักเรียนชอบสงสัยครูเอกก็สงสัยด้วย
โอเคค่ะโอเคก็จะมีมีบาทมีย่ามที่ข้างใน
เป็นของใช้แล้วก็มีกรดนะคะ
มีอะไรอีกคะที่ต้องเอาก่อนมีมีข้อควร
ปฏิบัติสิ่งที่ควรจะทำในการที่เดินธุดงค์
[เพลง]
ข้อที่ 1 ก็คือ
อันนี้
ชุดของพระเรียกอีกใช่ก็คือให้ใช้พระให้
ใช้ผ้าให้พระเนี่ยใช้ผ้าที่
มาจากผ้าที่เป็นผ้าบังสกุลคือผ้าที่ไม่
ใช้แล้ว
ผ้าบังสกุลก็คือสมัยโบราณนะในสมัยโบราณ
ผ้าบาง
เป็นผ้าที่ห่อห่อขนตายใช่แล้วเอาผ้านั้น
น่ะมาย้อมสีย้อมสีสีที่ทำมาจากเปลือกของ
ต้นไม้
ก็จะมีสีนี้สีคล้ายๆแบบนี้ในสมัยโบราณนะ
ใช่
อันนั้นสมัยโบราณสมัย 2,500 กว่าปี
ก็คือต้องต้องมีคนตายแล้วก็เอาผ้ามาแล้ว
ก็เย็บเย็บแล้วก็ไปซักแล้วก็มามาเปลี่ยน
สีจากต้นไม้ใช้ต้นไม้มาย้อมสีใช้สีจากต้น
ไม้มาย้อมสีภาคเพราะว่าภาพที่ห่อศพเป็นสี
ขาว
ก็เลยต้องมาย้อมให้เป็นสีสีเปลือกไม้
เพราะว่าจะได้เอ่อจะได้ไม่เห็นว่ามันเลอะ
ง่าย
อาหารก็ใช้สีเปลือกไม้อันนี้คือข้อที่ 1
นะข้อที่ 1 แล้วปัจจุบัน
เขาไม่มีผ้าสีขาว
ห่อคนตายแล้ว
ปัจจุบันเนี่ยก็คือการที่พระจะมาเอา
เปลือกไม้มาย้อมสีผ้าเนี่ยมันยากแล้วมัน
ไม่เหมือนสมัยโบราณต้นไม้ก็หายากนะครับ
ถ้าก็หายากนะครับเพราะฉะนั้นปัจจุบันเรา
ก็ข้อนี้ก็จะไม่ได้ใช้ไม่ได้ไม่ใช้ผ้าจาก
ผ้าห่อศพแล้วไม่ต้องมาย้อมผ้าเองพระสงฆ์
ไม่ต้องมายอมพลาดจากเปลือกไม้ด้วยตัวเอง
แล้วแต่ว่าเวลาที่นักเรียนคะเวลาที่ที่
ครอบครัวเรามีคนตายนะคะก็จะมีเอ่อช่วงนึง
ที่เราจะเชิญพระมาเราก็ทำบังสกุลบางทีเรา
ก็จะมีเนี่ยค่ะชุดผ้าของพระเนี่ยนะคะแล้ว
ก็ผวา
ก็ใช้ได้เนาะก็ใช้ได้เหมือนกัน
แต่ถ้าย้อมผ้าสำหรับที่ย้อมเปลือกไม้บาง
วัดยังมีอยู่นะคะบางวัดถ้าเป็นวัดที่เอ่อ
ยังเคร่งครัดในการปฏิบัติมากๆอย่างเช่น
เป็นวัดป่า
ก็ยังมีอันนี้เป็นกฎข้อที่ 1 นะข้อที่ 1
ครับส่วนข้อที่ 2 ก็คือพระธุดงค์พระ
ธุดงค์จะใช้ผ้าใช้ผ้าที่ห่มนะครับแค่ 3
ผืนมีอะไรบ้างคะอ่ามีมีเป็นภาพพื้นที่
หนึ่งเราเรียกว่าสบง
คือผ้าส่วนนี้ผ้าส่วนล่างที่พระใช้
สมองนะครับ
ตรงนี้มองเห็นนะครับอยู่ท่อนล่างครับที่
ใช้กับท่อนล่าง
[เพลง]
เป็นผืนนี้
เป็นภาพ
[เพลง]
พื้นที่ 3 ราคา
คืนนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะอ่าผืนนี้เรียกว่า
สังคติ
สังฆาฏิเป็นผ้าที่พาดอยู่พาดอยู่ที่ที่
ไหล่ลงมา
มีคำถามด้วย
ครับเวลาที่ตัวไหนข้างล่างข้างล่างเนี่ย
เรียกว่าสบงใช่ไหมคะ
ท่านเป็นผ้าผืนใหญ่ๆใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็
ต้องผูกยังไงคะเป็นผ้าผืนใหญ่ๆแบบนี้ยาวๆ
แบบนี้แล้วก็พันไปรอบๆตัว
พันไปรอบๆตัว
พอพันไปรอบๆตัวจะมีมีสายรัด
แบบนี้
แล้วก็เอาสายรัดเนี่ยรัดไว้เอามาผูกกัน
นะสำหรับรัฐสบงเอาไว้
แล้วก็ชิ้นที่ 2 คือจีวรใช่ห่มจีวรใช้ห่ม
ทั้งตัวใช่ครับ
แล้วผืนสุดท้ายสังฆาฏิที่ครูเอกสงสัย
สังฆาฏิไว้ที่ทำอะไรไว้พลาดเฉยๆเหรอคะใช่
ครับไว้พลาดเฉยๆไว้พลาดเฉยๆแล้วก็บางที
บางทีเวลานอนเราก็ใช้สังกะติกลางออกมา
เป็นภาพผืนใหญ่ก็เป็นผ้าห่มได้
[เพลง]
เข้าใจแล้วขอบคุณค่ะแล้วก็ต้องมีผ้าครบ 3
ผืนนะ
ครับต่อไปข้อที่ 3 ข้อที่ 3 ก็คือ
บิณฑบาตร
รับบิณฑบาตอย่างเดียว
ไม่รับนิมนต์ไปฉันอาหารที่บ้านไม่ได้ไม่
ได้อ๋อหมายความว่าคือประมาณตอนเช้าๆก็
ต้องเดินบิณฑบาตร
แต่ว่าถ้ามีคนมาบอกว่าอ้อนิมนต์ไปที่บ้าน
หน่อย
โอเคก็บิณฑบาตตอนเช้าแล้วก็บิณฑบาตแค่
เวลาเดียวนะกี่โมงคะ
อาจจะเป็นช่วงเช้าเป็นช่วงเช้านะครับ
เพราะคนไทยส่วนใหญ่เราก็ทำบุญใส่บาตรตัก
บาตรกันตอนเช้าเพราะฉะนั้นก็พระก็จะ
บิณฑบาตรตอนเช้า
[เพลง]
สายๆไม่ได้แล้วไม่ได้ไม่ได้นะครับ
แล้วก็
เดี๋ยวนะ
[เพลง]
ไม่สามารถเลือกได้
ไม่สามารถเลือกได้ว่าจะไปบิณฑบาตรที่ไหน
ถ้าเวลาเดินธุดงค์เวลาเดินธุดงค์ก็จะเดิน
ไปเรื่อยๆเดินไปเรื่อยๆถ้าคิดว่าอ๋อที่
นี่มีหมู่บ้านเยอะมีบ้านคนเยอะแล้วจะไป
บิณฑบาตรที่นี่ทุกวันไม่ได้
ใช่
ก็คือต้องไปเรื่อยๆใช่ต้องไปเรื่อยๆเลือก
ไม่ได้เลือกไม่ได้
ถ้าสมมุติว่า
ตรงป่านี้ถ้าท่านเดินออกมาแล้วก็มีหมู่
บ้านอยู่ที่นี่
ท่านก็ไปหมู่บ้านนี้ทุกวันไม่ได้ไม่ได้
ไม่ได้ต้องไปที่อื่นไปที่อื่นแล้วก็กลับ
มา
คนที่หมู่บ้านนี้รออยากทำบุญนะคะ
ไม่ได้ท่านไม่สามารถไปซ้ำที่เดิมได้ต้อง
ไปที่อื่นไปเรื่อยๆ
[เพลง]
ก็คือก็คือละเว้นการบิณฑบาตซ้ำที่เดิม
งั้นก็แสดงว่า
ท่านก็จะ
เปลี่ยนที่เปลี่ยนที่ไปไม่ได้ใช่กฎก็ปัก
ที่เดิมไม่ได้ใช่ครับต้องเปลี่ยนไป
ที่เดิมได้
อ๋อเข้าใจแล้วขอบคุณมากค่ะครูอาร์ตี้ครู
เอ๋ก็สงสัยว่าทำไมพระธุดงค์ท่านต้องเดิน
ไปเรื่อยๆก็คือจะได้ไม่ติดไม่ติดสบายหรือ
ไม่ติดลำบากก็ได้ไม่ยึดติดไม่ยึดติดกับ
ที่เดิมที่ความสบายเดิมๆนะครับก็จะต้อง
แสวงหาที่อื่นต่อไปเดินธุดงค์ไปเรื่อยๆ
เข้าใจแล้วต่อไปข้อ 5 ข้อ 5 ข้อต่อไปข้อ
ต่อไปก็คือ
ทานอาหารทานอาหารมื้อเดียว
เดินเยอะๆแต่ฉัน 1 มือเดียวใช่ครับวันละ
วันละ 1 มื้อเท่านั้นเพราะอาหารรวมกัน
ด้วยไหมคะ
มีเวลาที่เวลาที่ใกล้เคียงกันในทุกๆวัน
หลังจากที่อาหาร
ไม่ไม่สามารถที่จะบอกบอกว่าเอาวันนี้วัน
นี้หิวหิวเร็วออกไปบิณฑบาตรแล้วก็ฉัน
อาหารไม่ได้ต้องสารอาหารในเวลาใกล้เคียง
กับเวลาเดิมทุกๆวันนั้นแต่ละรูปเหมือนกัน
ไหมเหมือนกันไม่ใช่หมายความว่าต้องฉัน
เวลาเดียวกันไหมคะอ๋อถ้าไปถ้าตอนนั้นไป
บิณฑบาต 3 รูป
ไปธุดงค์ 3 รูปก็ฉันอาหารพร้อมๆกัน
ครูเอกกำลังหมายความว่าถ้าสมมุติว่าพระ
พระ 3 รูปนี้ไปธุดงค์ที่นี่แล้วเดินไป
บิณฑบาตโอเคเดินไปปั๊บมีคนทำบุญกลับมาอีก
1 ชั่วโมงมีคนตักบาตรแล้วก็กลับมาแต่ถ้า
พระที่อยู่จังหวัดนี้เดินไปโอ้ 10 กม
ถ้าเดินเดินธุดงค์คนละที่กันไม่เป็นไรไม่
เป็นไร
เพราะว่าเพราะว่ากำลังคิดว่าเอ๊ะเวลาที่
จะเจอคนที่ทำบุญตักบาตรอาจจะไม่ตรงกันใช่
ครับก็ถ้าเดินธุดงค์แยกกันก็ฉันไม่พร้อม
กันได้แต่ต้องฉันพระองค์เดิมองค์นั้นต้อง
ฉันเวลาใกล้ๆเคียงกันทุกๆวันและแล้วถ้า
เกิดวันนั้นวันนั้นน่ะวันนั้นเดินไปไม่มี
คนตักบาตรและตักบาตรช้าก็เลยไป 1 ชั่วโมง
ได้ไหมอนุโลมได้ได้ถ้าไม่มีถ้าไม่มีคนตัก
บาตร
แต่ถ้าทั้งวันไม่มีคนตักบาตรวันนั้นก็ไม่
ฉันไม่ต้องฉัน
สมมุตินะครูแอนตี้สมมุติว่าทุกวันจะมีคน
ตักบาตรประมาณ 8 โมงครึ่งเสร็จแล้วโอเค
ประมาณ 8 โมงท่านฉันอาหาร
ก็ต้องประมาณ 8 โมงถึง 9 โมงเนาะฉันอาหาร
เวลานี้แต่ถ้าวันนั้นน่ะบังเอิญท่านไป
เดินบิณฑบาตแล้วยังไม่เจอคนใส่บาตรแต่คน
ไปใส่บาตรตอน 9 โมงแล้วกว่าท่านจะเดิน
กลับมาที่พักก็ 10 โมงอย่างเงี้ยท่านฉัน
ตอน 10:00 นได้
อนุโลมได้
แต่ถ้าแต่ถ้าเลยเลยเที่ยงไปแล้วฉันไม่ได้
แล้ว
[เพลง]
โอเคขอบคุณค่ะข้อต่อไปค่ะโอเคข้อต่อไปข้อ
ต่อไปก็คืออันนี้ครับเมื่อกี้นี้เวลาฉัน
อาหารต้องฉันในบาตรฉันในบ่ายแล้วใส่อาหาร
ทุกอย่างลงไปในบาตรรวมกัน
ถ้าเป็นวัดที่เคร่งมากๆต้องคนรวมกันด้วย
หรือว่าวางไว้ในบาทรวมกันก็ได้ต้องวางรวม
กันเพราะว่าเพื่อที่จะฉันอาหารเพราะว่า
ให้มีชีวิตอยู่ไม่ได้ฉันอาหารเพราะว่า
อาหารอร่อยอ๋อไม่ต้องอันนี้อร่อย
อันนี้เป็นขนมอันนี้เป็นข้าวอันนี้เป็น
ไม่ต้องคิดแค่ฉันอย่างเดียว
ใช่ครับ
ส่วนหน้าที่ทำอาหารอร่อยเป็นหน้าที่ของคน
ใช่ครับบางคนคนจะชอบอันนี้อร่อยกินอันนี้
ก่อนแต่ถ้าพระเลือกไม่ได้ครับกินรวมกัน
เลยรวมกันแต่ว่าปกติเวลาคนทำอาหารใส่บาตร
ก็จะทำอาหารดีๆแล้วก็ใส่บาตรนะคะเพราะว่า
พระท่านเลือกไม่ได้แต่เราเลือกให้ท่านได้
เลือกเลือกอาหารไปทำบุญได้เลือกอาหารที่
ดีอาหารที่อร่อยให้พระนะครับ
มีอะไรคะกฎข้อต่อไปข้อต่อไปข้อที่ 7 ข้อ
ที่ 7
ข้อที่ 7 ก็คือ
เอ่อ
ละเว้นท์การฉันอาหารเหลือ
ก็คือถ้ามีอาหารเท่าไหร่ใส่ลงไปในบาตร
แล้วมีเท่าไหร่เนี่ยต้องฉันให้หมด
ห้องฉันให้หมดห้ามห้ามฉันเหลือเดี๋ยวๆๆ
แต่ถ้าสมมุติไปบิณฑบาตรแล้วคน
เอาอาหารใส่บาตรเยอะมากล่ะเราต้องต้องไม่
ใส่รวมกันในบาตรเพราะตอนที่จะฉันตอนที่
ฉันเราต้องแยกออกแยกออกว่าคิดว่าอ๋อแค่
นี้เราฉันหมด
ถ้ามากเกินก็ไม่ต้องใส่มาก็ที่เหลือก็อาจ
จะแยกออกไว้แล้วก็เอาไปบริจาคให้ให้คนที่
ทำต่อไป
ไปไม่ได้หรือให้
อาจจะให้คนแถวนั้นหรือไม่ก็อาจจะให้นกให้
สิ่งมีชีวิตอื่น
ข้อนี้เพื่อที่ต้องการให้พระรู้จักรู้จัก
ว่าตนเองฉันแค่ไหนพอฉันแค่ไหนมากเกินไป
แค่ไหนน้อยเกินไปให้รู้จักเรียกว่าประมาณ
ตนเองพอดีนะครับ
ต้องรู้ว่าตนเองฉันแค่ไหนถึงจะพอสั่นแค่
ไหนโอเค
[เพลง]
ข้อต่อไปข้อ 9 ข้อ 8 ข้อ 8 ใช่ครับ
ข้อ 8 ก็คือละเว้นการอยู่ในสถานที่ที่ไม่
เปลี่ยวก็คือไม่อยู่ในที่ที่ไม่อยู่ในที่
ชุมชนที่ที่มีคนเยอะๆไม่ควรอยู่ที่แบบ
สบายๆไม่ได้แพงมาก
วิ่งไปวิ่งมาไม่ได้ต้องเข้าไปอยู่ในป่า
ถ้าเป็นสมัยก่อนถ้าเป็นสมัยก่อนการอยู่ใน
ป่าก็อาจจะเป็นอยู่ในป่าช้า
ป่าช้าทีม
ป่าช้าคือที่ที่สั่งศพคนตายที่ฝังศพคนตาย
ก็จะไม่มีผลดี
มีป่าช้าคู่เอก
ยังไม่ตายเอาเป็นชื่อคนตายนะครับเป็นคน
ตาย
[เพลง]
ไปพักอยู่ที่นั่นนะครับ
ไม่อยู่ในที่ที่มีคนเยอะๆไม่อยู่ในที่ชุม
ชน
มีคำถามตอนครูแอนตี้บวชเป็นพระ
อยู่ในป่าช้าด้วยไหมคะ
ไม่เคยกลัวที่ยังไม่เคยไปเดินธุดงค์ไม่
เคยธุดงค์แต่ที่วัดที่โคโยตี้บวชเนี่ยก็
มีป่าช้าเหมือนกันแล้ว
ไม่ต้องเข้าไปนั่งในป่าช้าใช่ไหม
ครับแต่ก็ไม่เดินผ่านเดินผ่านเพราะว่า
วัดวัดที่โคโยตี้อยู่
ก็จะมีมีวัดมีป่าช้าอยู่ตรงกลางแล้วก็มี
เจดีย์มีเจดีย์อยู่ตรงนี้
เวลาที่จะต้องไปทำกิจกรรมธรรมะที่เจดีย์
ก็ต้องเดินผ่านป่าช้าไป
ก็ไม่เคยไม่เคยเห็นผีนะ
ไม่ใช่เงียบสงบเงียบไม่ได้พูดถึงผีเงียบ
สงบใช่ครับเงียบสงบมีเสียงใบไม้แป๊บๆมี
เสียงนกร้องอ่าเป็นบางเวลา
ตอนกลางคืนก็จะเงียบสงบเหนื่อยนอนหลับ
บางทีก็รีบเดินรีบเดินกลับวัด
ครูเอ๋ก็ไม่เคยค่ะตอนกลางคืนนะคะไม่เคย
อยู่ในป่าช้าแต่เคยอยู่ตอนกลางวัน
ตอนกลางวันก็เป็นป่าเป็นป่าไม่มีอะไรน่า
กลัว
ไม่มีคนตายมากๆไม่ได้
จะได้สงบนะครับจะได้ปฏิบัติธรรมได้อย่าง
สงบนะครับ
ต่อไป
ข้อต่อไปข้อ 9 ก็คือ
ละเว้นการนอนในที่ที่
มีมี
เพื่อนเป็นอาคารก่อสร้างนะครับต้องอยู่
ตามคนต้นไม้แบบนี้อยู่ตามคนต้นไม้ไม่อยู่
ในที่ไม่อยู่ในบ้านไม่อยู่ใน
ในถ้ำได้เป็นธรรมชาติอยู่ได้
ถ้าเป็นถ้ำเป็นสถานที่ที่เกิดจากธรรมชาติ
สามารถอยู่ได้
เป็นถ้ำอย่างนี้เป็นภูเขาแล้วก็มีถ้ำอยู่
ถ้ำอยู่ข้างในและเข้าไปอยู่ได้อยู่ในถ้ำ
แต่ถ้าเป็นอะไรที่คนทำขึ้นมาอย่างเช่น
บ้านถ้าเป็นบ้านเป็นสถานที่ก่อสร้างไม่
ได้เป็นวัดก็ไม่ได้ไม่ได้เหมือนกันนะครับ
เพราะว่าต้องเน้นที่อยู่ที่ธรรมชาติอยู่
ป่าอยู่ภูเขาอยู่ถ้ำได้
ไงครูเอ๋ที่ครูอาร์ตี้บอกว่าเหมือนร่มนี่
คือกรดหมดเวลากลางออกมาแล้วกลางออกมาแล้ว
ก็จะเหมือนลมนะครับ
อันนี้
เขามี
เสาไหมคะ
ตัวนี้เขาผูกไว้กับเชือกมีพืชเชือกผูกไว้
ตรงนี้มีเสาสั้นๆ
มีเสาถ้ามีเสายาวลงมาที่พื้นมันจะติด
มันจะติดเวลาเรานั่งก็จะติดเสาเพราะ
ฉะนั้นก็จะไม่มีเสาจริงๆครูเอ๋ไม่รู้ไง
ครูเอ๋เข้าใจว่าครูเอกเข้าใจว่ามีเสาแล้ว
ก็เสียบลงไปอ๋อไม่ใช่เป็นเสาสั้นๆแล้วก็
ผูกเชือกผูกเชือกไว้กับข้างบนผูกเชือกไว้
กับต้นไม้กับกิ่งไม้ข้างบน
เอาไว้กันแดดกันฝนเนาะ
เวลานอนก็จะมีมุ้งมีมุ้งกำลังจะถาม
แต่ว่าไม่ได้ใหญ่มากไม่ใหญ่มาก
เวลานอน
พระธุดงค์ไม่นอน
นะ
ง่วงนอนก็นอนไม่ได้นะไม่ได้
[เพลง]
นั่งสมาธิ
ใช่ครับนั่งสมาธินะครับแล้วก็เข้าฌานไป
ไม่นอนไม่นอนเพราะว่าโกรธโกรธมีขนาดเล็ก
นิดเดียวกรดเล็กๆ
เท่ากับเท่ากับเรานั่งได้พอดีในกรด
ถ้านอนนี่คงต้องขดตัวแบบนี้
สงสัยมาตลอดเลยนะว่าท่านจะนอนยังไงแล้ว
ท่านจะนอนยังไงนะไม่นอนครับต้องนั่งสมาธิ
ครับ
เข้าฌานตั้งใจปฏิบัติธรรมแล้วก็กลับไปนอน
ที่วัดหลังจากเดินธุดงค์เสร็จแล้ว
ใช่ครับก็นั่งสมาธิแบบนี้
[เพลง]
ข้อต่อไปค่ะ
ข้อต่อไป
ข้อต่อไปก็คือ
ข้อนี้ข้อนี้ก็คือการคล้ายๆกับข้อที่แล้ว
นะครับอ่า
ต้นไม้นะครับให้อยู่ใต้ต้นไม้อยู่กลาง
แจ้งนะครับ
โอเคให้อยู่กลางแจ้งนะครับ
ข้อต่อไปข้อ 11 นะครับ
ละเว้นอยู่ในที่ที่ใกล้กับบ้านบ้านคนให้
อยู่ในที่ที่ห่างไกลผู้คนนะครับ
ระยะทางประมาณอยู่ห่างกันประมาณ 1 กิโล
ประมาณนะ
ประมาณ 1 กิโล
อยู่ห่างจากบ้านคนเนี่ยประมาณ 1 กิโล
ข้อต่อไปก็ 12 ก็คือ
อะไรคะไม่ยึดติดไม่ยึดติดในที่พักโอเคอัน
นี้ก็คือข้อเมื่อกี้ไม่พักอยู่ที่เดิมนาน
ๆแต่ไม่ยึดติดต้นไม้ใหญ่สบายแล้ว
ลมดีนะครับใกล้กับที่บิณฑบาตไม่ยึดติด
ต้องย้ายไปย้ายไป
ข้อสุดท้ายข้อสุดท้ายคืออะไรคะข้อนี้ครับ
คืออิริยาบถแค่ 3 อย่างอะไรบ้างคะอ่ามี
เดิน
เดินแล้วก็ยืน
ยืนแล้วก็นั่ง
ไม่มีนอนไม่มี
นอนถือ
ไม่มีนอนเลยหรอ
เดินก็คืออาจจะเป็นเดินบิณฑบาตเดินธุดงค์
เดินจงกรมนั่งก็คือนั่งสมาธิ
ยืนก็คืออาจจะเป็นยืนเวลาที่นั่งนานๆแล้ว
เมื่อยนั่งนานๆแล้วจะหลับใช่ไหมก็ยืนยืน
ทำสมาธิหรือเดินจงกรม
แค่ 3 อย่างนี้เท่านั้น
เป็นพระธุดงค์ไม่ง่ายเนาะไม่ง่ายครับไม่
ง่ายเลยต้องใจแบบ
ต้องมีความตั้งใจมากๆ
แล้วก็ฝึกฝึกร่างกายนะครับฝึกความอดทนฝึก
ความมุ่งมั่นที่จะ
ปฏิบัติธรรมนะครับ
โอเคและนี่ก็เป็น
ข้อกำหนดทั้ง 13 ข้อในการที่อยากจะออกไป
เดินธุดงค์
[เพลง]
ขอบคุณครูอาร์ตี้ค่ะที่
เล่าให้ครูอีกฟังนะ
ใกล้ๆบ้านประมาณ 1 กิโลเมตร
รู้จักมากขึ้นแล้วนะครับโอเควันนี้เราสอง
คนก็หมดเวลาแล้วครับเดี๋ยวเรากลับมาเจอ
กันใหม่ในคราวหน้านะครับคลิปต่อไปเราจะมา
เล่าเรื่องอะไรนะครับคอยติดตามกันนะครับ
ที่ช่องนี้ complainable ไทยเหมือนเดิม
วันนี้ลาไปก่อนแล้วครับอ่าสวัสดีครับพี่
เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีครับ